こんにちは、クリスと申します。今日はDrupalDEN岩国でスペシャルトークをすることになり、光栄です。
今日は沖縄科学技術大学院大学の
リニューアルされたウェブサイトを発表します。
英語で技術的な内容を発表した方がやりやすいのですが、
それでも後で日本語でお話しして、ご意見をいただくのが楽しみです。
Good afternoon. My name is Chris
and my honor to be here to give a special talk today at the DrupalCamp Iwakuni.
Our University, OIST
build the Drupal 7 site in 2011,
which was the first year of its release.
Drupal 7 had the longest lifespan among all the versions,
and brought significant changes to this platform.
One of these change was the integration of CCK as the content type entity field.
It brought test-driven development to the core.
Additionally, ImageCache was transformed into that ImageStyle.
Last year,
we underwent a two-year journey to rebuild and modernize the website using Drupal 9.
In the first part of the talk I will discuss the development and the project management process went through during the website rebuild.
In the second part of my talk,
will delve deeper into the challenges we faced when localizing the website
for our bilingual English and Japanese audiences.
I will share the issue we encountered beyond just translation, and how we address them to provide the best experience to our users.
First.
a little bit about myself.
I'm a Drupal developer with 14 years of experience in Drupal development.
I have extensive experience in web design and development in traditional Chinese, Japanese, and English.
I'm also a member of the Drupal community, and a former group leader in Taiwan
Outside of Drupal, I'm also interested in coffee, Germany, and cats, and welcome any conversation about those topics as well.
Before jumping to the topic.
Please note that any mention of the vendor or products in this talk are not endorsement
Our old Drupal 7 side served us well. Bringing in over 30 million visits,
and deliver 37,000 pieces of mountain.
In the last 3 years we doubled our monthly visit.
The website shares our accomplishment with the world, such as when we have a new lab building were completed
when we received high impact rankings in Nature, and when our faculty member won the Nobel Prize recently.
The website continuously to celebrate the success.
However, we continue to strive for innovation and shape the future of research in Japan.
In order to reach these goals.
We have to set the new objectives and needed a new website that could deliver our outcome in a more effective and flexible way.
In 2020 OIST set a
strategic plan, and begin to
emphasize the 3 pillar of activities: Research, Education, and Innovation.
It is also our responsibility to raise the awareness of STEM education, contribute to Okinawa and conduct outreach activities in the Japanese society.
Throughout the entire project, we kept these 3 main pillars in mind
and made sure that all the website aligned with the organization strategics.
From a technical perspective, our goal was to improve the accountant management experience for editors.
Drupal 9 allows us to use the media library to manage assets
and change the Node translation method to field translation.
In addition to Drupal, we also implement a design system to maintain the consistency in user experience and enable editors to easily reuse web component when creating content.
The website project was divided into 3 main phases.
We conducted a comprehensive user research with a vendor in December, 2020 to gain better understanding of the stakeholders, both internal and external users.
The study helped us identify how users perceive us.
and how we can improve the website information architecture
In the second phase we hire another vendor to migrate the content and build a new website using Drupal 9.
After the vendor completed the development.
our web team took over the content.
We convert it and recreate the content and train the content owner on how to use the new website.
Our developer and I also work on updating and resolving any additional issues.
Last December, 2 years after we began the project, we successfully relaunch the website.
It has been well received by the OIST community.
Let's take a quick tour of the site now
We redefine the color scheme and use the new web component throughout the site.
The Mega menu provide the user with a better navigation map.
Our media editor can mainly select the related content, or let the system choose a related content for them.
We integrate the flickr into the site
to allow us to preview our photo albums
for different campaign or special committees.
We have a microsite feature
which allows them to manage their own content and display their own logo.
Finally, we have also created a style guide to showcase the components
we design for the website.
Now let's moved on to the technical aspect of our project.
I would like to provide a high-level overview of the migration process, and how we manage the Development project.
Migration was the first and the most important factor in our project.
All important content and assets need to be migrated.
It wasn't just about migrating the content node. We also had to migrate files and image that were not managing in the CMS.
In Drupal 7,
there was no Media Library, so we used the "Video" and "Photo" content type to contain assets, and later use the short code to reference them in the content body.
This means we had to migrate all 3,000 content nodes and over 6,000 media assets first.
and then convert all the inline circle into the new media embed format.
In the past,
content editors were able to use the IMCE to upload the files and image to the server directly.
During the migration we converted over 1,500 inline file sources into media types,
including images, documents, and embedded videos. This not only ensure that all the files in the managed system, but also
makes the system more secure.
In total, we migrate more than 10,000 content and assets via the Drupal Migrate API script.
The migrate profile was kept in use in the project to provide mockup data for testing purpose.
During each feature development, our local environment and cloud CI environment builds the site with the mockup data every time.
This allows us to run the unit test repeatedly
and make our deployment more robust and reliable.
Migration was critical to the project.
and require a lot of efforts to review, content, and validate the results but it was worth it.
and play the crucial role in the project's success.
Beyond migration,
There were 3 keys that make the project success.
We made sure to keep our team and the Supervisor informed of our progress.
OIST is a large organization, with many decision making channel. So when necessary, we met the stakeholder directly, and then find someone who could support and communicate
to the right channel.
We use a tool effectively to manage project tasks and assist with the communication.
There is no best tool but we find the right tool that all team members were willing to use.
To reduce repetitive tasks and risks,
we rely on test and automation process as much as possible.
All these factors work together to make the project a success.
During the first stage of the project, when we work with the vendor
they use the Github and its project tool to manage the tasks.
This allowed their developer and us to communicate freely
rather than only through the project manager.
This accelerate development made the work transparent and increase the mutual trust.
After the project was delivered, we introduced Shortcut to manage both development and content creation tasks on the same platform
With Shortcut, we were able to integrate Github to track the status of the PR and syncing development task status.
Many of us already familiar with Github and their project managed tool have been more mature and user-friendly, now.
Shortcut is a task management system that can easily manage both development and editing tasks.
Given that the task of development and editing require different workflow,
we can create different workflow in shortcut for them.
and then bring them into the same epic or iteration easily.
This is very helpful for a team with multiple functions.
In shortcut. We can quickly sync the status of dev tasks with Github.
even though they are two separate platform, we can work between them seamlessly.
We are a two-developer development team and need to focus on tasks and resolving issues.
The CI/CD process act as a third developer.
checking the code standard and deploying the code for us.
This allow our developer to quickly move on to the next task after committing the code to the online development environment.
Once the commit passed the CI/CD workflow,
we can then focus on reviewing the logic of the code in pull request.
And then ask the CI/CD to deploy it to the production site.
With all the tools, script, and continuous communication.
we were able to complete the project smoothly.
Of course, the diligent team members
were the core of the project's success.
OIST is a unique graduate university in Japan, with over 50% of our
members being international, including employees and students.
Our Cell signal Unit is a diverse example.
With the leading faculty. fellow researchers and students from different countries.
As a result,
English and Japanese are equally important at OIST,
and most of the content on our website is translated into both languages
During the project we dealt with many translations issues, and in the second part of this talk.
I'd like to focus on a few of them, particularly for our Japanese and APAC region attendees today.
Drupal has well-defined translation system in core.
Depends on your experience and role.
There are always ways for you to make translations
As a site builder,
We can translate nodes with the field translation enabled.
Also, we can translate many strings that appears in the user interface.
As a themer, we use TWIG to mark translatable sentence with a variable in it.
As a developer,
we can mark the translatable string with the t() function.
It is also capable to use dynamic variable in the sentence.
However, there might be a chance that we need a translation context,
because a word could be verb or noun, or has more than one meaning.
For example,
"Contact"
It will be translated into two different words in Japanese
as the action "コンタクト"
or as a section label in "連絡先".
There are more details about localizing user experience in my talk at the latest DrupalCon Prague.
If you're interested and work on bilingual sites often, it would be helpful for you. But today I want to focus on the issues specific to the project and related to the Japanese languages.
One issue to consider is the date format
in Japan
as well as in Taiwan.
We typically use a format that starts with the year followed by the months and day.
In the other country we often see this date format.
which can be interpreted
as either September 12th or December 9th, depending on the country. For example, most European countries read it as December 9th, while the United States.
read it as September 12th.
Given the diversity of our University members.
we have to find a common way to ensure our understanding of information is consistent.
Therefore we use the ISO 8601 format in English UI, as it is the same order
of format for the Japanese UI.
Another issue to consider is typing in Japanese, Chinese, or Korean, often referred to as CJK languages.
Typing Roman alphabet on a keyboard is relatively easy. But how are words typed in CJK languages?
Here are some paragraph in CJK about "What to do if you receive the positive COVID-19 notification from the Health Center".
you can see
that in CJK languages
the sentence rarely have spaces.
To index the content to the database and make it easy to search.
Sometimes we need extra treatment.
So how do we type? What's this CJK keyboard looks like?
From the left to right
we see two traditional Chinese keyboards.
and there are two Korean keyboards layouts, and two Japanese layouts, one in mobile, and the other one is a compact keyboard with the 50
essential sounds characters.
For those who don't understand the language.
They may look like a puzzle, right?
When typing the words, the keystrokes vary.
For the word "Computer".
we can also tell. It is different in traditional Chinese used in Taiwan or simplified Chinese in China
when typing CJK text, a word is completed only when all the segments is typed.
Unlike typing English.
there might be possible worry combination before finish the typing.
In this clip
it shows that inputting
Japanese kanji requires typing one to four or even more the phonetic elements.
Additionally.
there are different words in Kanji, which have the same pronunciation.
This can lead to an issue in the search box,
where the search is triggered too early before the actual keyword is completed.
which can be annoying for the users.
This issue can be improved by implementing a special JavaScript event method to wait for the completion of the keyword input
before the people triggering the search.
In this clip
we can see some improvement.
We can find the English typing words normally, and the Japanese word for Corona only queries the result when the word is completed.
In Drupal, there are autocomplete fields for tags or referencing entities.
The core had the issue before, but it was fixed in 2016.
Thanks to the Drupal contributors.
Mainly, it is the CompositionEvent that helps us to identify the special event when the typing is finished.
When we created this custom autocomplete search box, we had to implement the event as well.
First we detect the starting point of the CJK input method.
Next, we wait until the word is decided.
as we see the CompositionEnd event happens.
Finally, we send this AJAX request
After the typing issue. Let's see some sorting issue. In English, we even sort with the alphabet of the title of articles.
taxonomy tags or names, for example.
However, it is entirely different when sorting in Japanese or Chinese.
In Japanese language, most of us know it is
usually order with the 五十音
and also there are Kanji or Chinese characters, too.
when we have an array composed
of Latin letters, numbers, Hiragana, Katagana
and Kanji.
How do we sort them correctly?
The ideal order in Japanese language should looks like these on the right.
Starting with simple number alphabet like in English, and then Hiragana, Katagana, and the last part the Kanji.
Hiragana and Katagana follows the order of 五十音. But what is the order in Kanji?
If we use the sort() function directly.
it will usually sort the array based on an indexed number of each characters in the Unicode table.
However, this doesn't make sense for Japanese speakers, as the order of the characters doesn't reflect the proper way to sort them in the language.
One solution is to use the JavaScript function localeCompare(). this function sorts Kanji based on the pronunciation of the first character
and then the next character if the first characters is the same
In PHP, there is also a similar function to do the sorting, but it is recommended to use a database query for better sorting results from the backend.
However, this is not perfect yet. There is one word misplaced in the middle
岩下
It is because the Kanji has another pronunciation.
The first characters is read in an alternative way "がん"
rather than "いわ"
Another example, there is another last name can be called either かわの or こうの using the same Kanji.
So in Japanese or in Mandarin Chinese the character could have more than one pronunciation.
How many characters has more than one pronunciation?
Japanese country has more than 600 out of 2,000 common characters which has more than one pronounciations.
In the official definition from the Ministry of Education of Taiwan,
there were 1,200 out of 5,000 commonly used traditional Chinese characters
around 10 years ago
officials reviewed and merged many of them, reducing the number down to
Let's take the Kanji for example.
It has more pronunciation due to different cultural contexts.
Four of them are inherited from the ancient Chinese in various eras.
Another four represent the original Japanese language.
The original Chinese character looks very similar.
and it has three pronunciations.
The character stands for 樂 (yue) for "music" or 樂 (le) for "happy or happiness", or 樂 (yao) for the verb "to appreciate".
So we
now know Japanese sort by pronunciation. How about Madarin Chinese?
Let's bring some delicious Taiwanese food here.
They are in the order of
my preference
How do we sort their names using their attribute?
Let's first see what options do we have.
This is the first characters of Iwakuni
"Yán" in Mandarin.
There are at least four different ways to sort it.
We can count its radical strokes.
total strokes.
spell it with phonetical
elements 注音
which is only used in Taiwan, or Pinyin with roman characters which is the main input method in China.
Usually we order with one of the attributes.
And sometimes let the user change the sorting method. For instance, the book search system in a library
in traditional Chinese localeCompare() function also works with the various attributes that I mentioned before
By strokes
or by the phonetic 注音.
This is sorting with the phonetic element 注音. Similar way that we saw Japanese 五十音.
It would be difficult to understand, if you don't understand 注音.
But the other way be easier.
This is sorting in the total strokes.
we can see the first characters of each
has more strokes from left to right.
It's amazing that JavaScript supported, right.
It is all thanks to the open source contributors, especially in the Unihan project.
a sub branch project
under the Unicode open source project.
That makes this available.
Let's think about the unresolved issue, what to do with the multiple pronunciation in Kanji?
the issue affects Japanese Kanji, or a Chinese characters when sorting with the phonetic elements 注音 or Pinyin.
Technically, native speakers know the common variations of the pronunciation.
When we process in head, it is processed together.
It doesn't really bother the native speakers when the
different pronunciation mixed together.
However, my understanding could be wrong about Japanese.
I would be happy to hear from you what is the pratical solution here.
Sometimes, if the clients request to make it in a explicit order.
the better way is to map the word into a predefined table or array.
At the end, I want to share a sentence with you.
We hear people say
"Devil is in the details"
It means the difficulty or troubles is not revealed until you look close to the details.
The origin of the sentence is somehow opposite.
"神は細部に宿る"
It is from Germany
architecture, Mies van der Rohe.
"Der liebe Gott steckt im detail"
No matter it is devil or God.
The sentence has one thing in common.
The most important things are in the details.
When we see a new website is complete people cheering and feel satisfied.
When the visitor find the good experience using the website in their native tounge intuitively.
It is all because the developer designer work on every detail to bring the best UX
to our users.
Let's look closer and take the challenge,
deal with the devil.
We will find a glorious miracle in the end.
Thank you. I'm. Chris. I wish you a good afternoon today in the following sessions.
ご清聴ありがとうございました